ouais j'ai tout j'en ai encore une là
devant avant 20h c'est un vieux
bouton je me mets en route attends 2
secondes
elle est tout public
Laurent va rester un petit peu avec nous
on était dans la classe enfin j'y étais
moi et lui il était sur le pays écrivain
et il me faisait des trucs mais
imprononçable quoi des trucs que je peux
pas dire il était écroulé de rire
derrière la bagarre la barrière avec la
régie et il m'avait un certain âge
je l'ai quasiment vu débuter c'est
pareil il me faisait mourir de rire dans
les coulisses c'est ton style d'homme
à partir de ça
va falloir négocier le prix parce que
c'est une très belle femme Daniel Moreau
moi je l'ai connu
[Applaudissements]
il avait pas de bracelet électronique
quand je il devait rien à personne
il a [ __ ] tout Paris ouais
[Rires]
j'ai adoré mon ciel il y avait personne
à son enterrement j'étais triste
[Rires]
vous connaissez tout le monde ce mec et
personne ça m'a fait mal au coeur
il y avait un pauvre labrador qui
suivait le cercueil